mtv pulled off a miracle this year yeah
they created an amazing movie and tv
award show in a year with almost
no big movies thank you all for
supporting me i am truly honored
everybody michael maya it's kristin
yeah yeah kirsten stars aligned mostly
virtually
for the annual mtv movie and tv awards
which had to switch it up for 2020.
it's the first ever goat awards the
greatest
of all time and we deserve that after
the year that we've had
there was something different and
special about chadwick boseman
robert downey jr and don cheadle honored
their fellow avenger
with the hero for the ages award less
than four months after his
tragic passing shero winner
gal gadot gave fans a sneak peek at
wonder woman 1984
while dynamic duo winners adam sandler
and drew barrymore
gave us this tease it's a new decade so
we get to make another movie together
yeah drew and adam have made a movie
together in each of the last three
decades
back in september sandler told e.t he
was all in
for number four could we see you and
drew do another movie together
any time drew wants her she's just got
to tell me
last night sarah michelle geller and
selma blair gave us a cruel intentions
kiss
re-do with a 20-20 twist
stay safe mtv we always knew we were
doing something
really cool sarah remembered her iconic
scene with e.t last year
we were on the set in 1998. i had the
tongue in her mouth
i was torturing her
the besties who won for legendary lip
lock hung out at home during last
night's show and posted these before and
afters
selma and marc jacobs
speaking of fashion a blonde wig wearing
sia performed virtually
those were real-life dancers dressed as
dogs sia's dress was plastered with
pooches too
host vanessa hudgins rocked six
different outfits some paying homage to
pop culture classics like carrie and
posh spice
she even got into the karate kid spirit
all while getting tested to stay safe
yakova testia a lot of kova tests
you